do you like that in-between time
Jonathan when you have nothing going on
there just like this big ? in the air
like what am I going to do or do you
like more certainty honest answer I look
I just love working so if I could go and
i was told my manager and agent this if
i could go back to back to back to back
to back to back to back that's a
vacation i mean i don't really need a
vacation time I love working and I'm
young and I have the energy to do it I
just want to put good stuff out there so
yeah sometimes it's hard because I
wanted like do everything but you got to
really be you know you got to be picky
and do the right stuff and choose wisely
and do stuff that really speaks to you
but at the same time I just I want to
wear it constantly and why else does it
work for you aside from the fact that
you like being on set you like being
around the crew and everything but you
were saying earlier yeah I feel like
everything in my life I you know the all
the daily stresses and then anxiety
tends to go away when I'm working when I
can really focus my energy and put all
this this positive thinking into a
project and it really for me is a
positive thing working ah then
everything seems to always be better for
the times that you don't have something
going on what do you do to drum up
either work or your own projects you
know I I really i got make my own
content shorts and and and stuff like
that I'll do shorts with my friends I
like to do martial arts in my free time
I love my dog I love to hang out my
family my family's all in LA so that's
really nice and to drum up work I mean I
was just out there like everyone I'm
still part of the audition game out
there auditioning all the time so that
and acting classic go to acting class a
lot and focus on that and theatre I do
theatre when I can so it's just you know
is I'm trying to do something every day
to be better at what I do I always say
you don't go you know you don't see NFL
players get into the NFL and they
stopped practicing I think it's the same
thing with acting and uh I I can always
get better didn't you grew up in LA area
you probably saw so much happen I know
you're still so
so young but I'm sure you got a great
perspective of how this industry works
and ups and downs what's your take on it
because you still love it and you're
still active is there a mantra you tell
yourself is there something is there a
perspective that you have that keeps you
feeling fresh about it there is a
certain lifestyle as far as working and
constantly being working and certain
goals I have and I always tell myself
I'm like I want this certain lifestyle
and I will attain this certain lifestyle
I am attaining it now I'm in the process
of doing it and I do something every day
to get better at acting and i think that
there's there's a lot there's a lot of
uncertainty a lot of stuff that you
can't control but i do everything in my
power to control what I can control and
I can control my my productivity I can
control getting better at acting there
are things that can control so every
little thing I can do that that can you
know put me up there make make me a
better artist a you know a better person
I try to do that how does the martial
arts come into play oh well I mean it's
nice to decompress and hit some you
know I mean the oddest you know it can
be really stressful being an actor and
not knowing when your next job is and
it's nice to go do something that that I
work at and I get better and it's such a
tangible thing like I do it now rise
through the ranks and you're going to
rise through the ranks because you work
hard acting it's not really a certain
thing like that it's just you do what
you can but but with martial arts it's
like I think it also keeps me humble cuz
I you know I ice bar I go really hard
and there's always out some out there
there's always someone who could kick
your ass and I think it's you know I
think it's definitely humbled me a lot
because you know and also made me more
confident a lot of ways and made me more
centered but it's for decompression and
in humility and you know some people go
to therapy I i go to martial arts when
did you start martial arts ah man I
started like 107 and I took a while off
cuz I did all the childhood sports like
baseball basketball and then in high
school I played water polo and then when
after my third year water polo I had
some friends who were getting into
in jiu-jitsu and I'd done that as a kid
and I was just started doing it again
and I fell back in love with it and I've
been doing it since my junior of high
school when I was like 15 I'm like 20 24
now so been doing it for a while and
then I started kickboxing recently and
I'd done a little wrestling too would
you advise other actors to always have a
hobby or always have something else
because it sounds like the martial arts
you can kind of like maybe forget about
entertainment for a while yeah and just
focus on that yeah I think you got to
have other stuff in your life definitely
it makes you makes you more whole makes
you a more interesting person and I
think it's also important to have
friends who are not in the industry like
I have a lot of friends so I just go and
I just shoot the with and I I can
have fun with and I don't necessarily
talk about my career at all or what I'm
doing or what I'm not doing or it's nice
to have that that you know that normalcy
right where people see you as yeah it's
just like you to go to my gym you know
and do to train with not the actor or
the guy pursuing a career now the film
one light is about many things but it's
about narcissism and Hollywood and you
know with this element of social media
that especially everyone in your
generation is just they were pretty much
born into it what's your feeling about
that because as an actor you have to do
social media you have to promote
yourself yeah but is there a time when
you say you know what I'm not gonna look
at the phone yeah I mean it's there are
positive and negatives of anything in
the industry but especially with social
media I have so many people say such
wonderful things to me and so many
people who don't service will be people
you don't say dad see things you on
Twitter or whatever and you just kind of
got to put it aside and be grateful for
the people who are really nice and
really supportive of what you do I mean
there's instagram and twitter and i'm on
both I wasn't crazy about at first I was
a little later to get on Twitter and
Instagram the reason I do it is mostly
so that I have this this audience so
that when i do have projects people will
listen or watch or tweet or retweet
other than that I mean
sometimes it's not really my favorite
thing to do you know I do it a lot just
because I think it's really now part of
its ingrained in the industry now and I
think that it is important for the fact
that I I want the people who follow me
to know that that I'm an okay guy also I
I think that's cool to show them on
Instagram show them like some be playing
with my dog this my girlfriend it's my
family you know important stuff to me
and I think it's interesting there is
another side of it though what I think
that the interesting thing that used to
be about movies movie stars and I think
it's made kind of the whole allure of
movie stars disappear a little bit
because you know when there was James
Dean when there's Steve McQueen people
didn't know what they were doing their
private life and now you have TMZ and
you have twitter and you can always find
out and that's something that's sad
that's a little bit lost i think it's i
think it's really fascinating when you
don't know that much about a person so I
mean there is a lot I keep off of it no
one will really know no elements of the
true me but I don't think anyone's
really going to know who I am ever in my
career like really know me because I
would rather keep it that way there's a
lot that I'd rather keep in my private
life which is interesting because I
think that probably only comes from
having people try to access you because
I see a lot of people the opposite maybe
they haven't had that and they want to
show everything yeah it's five minutes
from now look at this and is that
somewhat what the film is about as well
I mean I'm not sure yeah I think that um
an important part of the film is just
that it it's nice to see a story where
they kind of explore that where they
would they show you maybe what you look
like to other people it's kind of turn
the camera around at people you know
they're so busy so focused on on taking
pictures with their friends or taking
pictures of themselves that they don't
notice maybe what it looks like to an
outside perspective and at the same time
like there are like i was saying there
are positive things about social media
like i said i get to show that i'm an
okay dude i'm a family oriented guy but
at the same time i don't really i don't
know a certain parts of privacy trip me
out a little and i don't want to really
give up everything and i think that our
people are willing to
there are people who crave more
attention than others definitely and I
think that's become a part of it where I
noticed especially young artists my age
focusing more on that more on the
branding of themselves and really the
talent and this project really explores
that which is cool about what it means
to be a star and what it means to be an
actor and and how people in the industry
view and how people outside the industry
view it tell me your character's name
again I'm playing rocky and I'm playing
miles chance the main character I'm
playing his friend in it I what is
Hollywood friend Oh interesting and is
that is that a friend of me you know
what I never really judged my characters
I think that a distance is like yourself
from the actual character so so I have
you you have to justify everything so
I'm not gonna be like oh I'm a friend of
me or I'm a bad guy I'm a dude who has
his reasons for what he does you know
there's there's a reason obviously for
better or worse that I'm friends with
him but I don't know what I really call
it besides uh you know a Hollywood
friend I'll leave it at that okay so
that's interesting so you don't judge
the character so then you don't want to
feel like they're good or bad either
yeah I mean like if you're if you're
playing a serial killer if you talk to
most like like there's a lot of
interviews on on killers or bat horrible
human beings they don't actually believe
they're a bad person they have a
justification and so I think every
person i mean that's in a really extreme
case but i think that every when you're
playing a certain character you can't
really i mean it's hard not to sometimes
because you'll look anybody well that's
a really mean thing to do or that's a
but you kind of gotta not pay attention
to that and really come up for reasons
and just to justify what you do in it if
that makes sense kind of like you can't
really judge yourself or then it's kind
of an outsider perspective and it's not
really the real realistic perspective
you've had if you were being that person
you look 24 but at your mind seems older
so that's that's awesome what do you
think that perspective comes from I I've
had a really uh I feel like I've lived a
lot I've had the best of both worlds
really i went to public school and I I
did the whole acting thing as a kid and
I got to live in different countries and
I don't talk to a lot of people meet a
lot of people and I I've really really
great parents and I think she's just the
environment being being able to travel
so much being able to meet so many
people and have a lot of experiences
just give them given me perspective but
I mean there's always I I I don't you
know look at myself and be like oh wow
I'm wise I I really think there's a lot
I could learn and there's you know a lot
of things I could prove about me and
improved pawn and and and try to expand
and try to learn but I don't know it's
just it's just interesting growing up
and kind of having a life in the
industry and then a total totally
different private life if there was
another actor that was around your age
that is like obsessed with the industry
and they and they're almost similar to
some of these characters that are in
limelight and they asked you for advice
what would you tell them in terms of
like you know have a hobby do other
things try to get out of I would to be
completely honest I'd say you know what
it's easy to find yourself yeah falling
into that you know I've been guilty that
before where I'm like wow I'm way to
focus on what other people think about
me what I need to be doing right now
where I guess I would just say live in
the moment you know if I'm 24 years old
I still got to remember that and I still
got to remember to have fun with my life
and hang out with my friends and not be
like what's next what's next what am i
doing next push harder you can do better
you got to have that certain element but
you also got to be a human and not not
an industry robot and I think it would
be just just live in the moment I think
that'd be my advice for me this is just
as someone that's Generation X I see a
lot of Millennials that seem more
competitive and maybe it's just because
the world has tightened up and it is it
everything's now more competitive
what you're feeling about competition
cuz there's good and bad to it and
sometimes that people do get wrapped up
and I think we've all been guilty of it
uh yeah um I I think that acting people
tend to think of it as a competitive
thing but I I've been really trying to
make a conscious effort because I've
been guilty that to not look at other
people and look I mean you can look and
admire and be like wow that guy he's my
age and he did a brilliant job in this
but I can't compare myself to anyone
else's path because the interesting
thing about the entertainment industry's
everybody has a different path yeah I'm
really competitive with myself you know
I know I can do better I know I can be
better i know i can i can work harder so
I'm really just competitive with myself
and competitive I I hold myself to a
high standard as far as work ethic and
trying to improve all the time and also
there's a certain you know like I said
there's a certain lifestyle as far as
working all the time that's a lifestyle
I want I want to be working a lot i want
to be working on great stuff and doing
great work and uh yeah it's hard to
balance that and then you know not try
to be good you know acting is about
living in it and you can't try to be
good or you're not really doing a good
job of acting so there's it's hard to
balance those two you had an 18 year old
brother who was thinking about getting
into the industry and wanted sort of a
big brother talk what would you say to
him treat it treat it like a job you
know as far as I'm going to try to
rephrase that treat it I treat it like
the hours of a job spend that many hours
a day trying to improve yourself as an
actor and focus more on classes then on
social media for focus more and actually
trying to try to be good at what you do
and I think that as much as there is a
lot of uncertainty to acting and there
is some luck involved i think a lot has
to be said for people who just work
their ass off I've seen a lot of people
who work their ass off rise to the top
and maybe you know not even
you know start and they didn't know it
like that for I hate when people say oh
you know you got to know somewhere to
start in the industry you know the thing
is you got it you got to work hard oh
there's a pup you just came by hey puppy
uh-uh you gotta you gotta work hard I
think that's the most important thing
and and our viewers may not know this
but it's like what two in the morning
right now yeah yeah it's two in the
morning oh I just had I stayed another
movie and had two days home and then I
started this all it's been it's been an
adventure mean that's why I'm open and
I'm talking so much maybe I'm just
really tired what's your typical day
like if let's say you're not on set like
what time do you usually get up and what
what do you do monday wednesday friday i
get up at six in the morning and I go
and I work out one of my best friend's a
trainer and try stay in really good
shape and I do that every scripts i go
to jiu-jitsu i go to kickboxing I've
acting class at night and then I do it
all over again and its variations on
that you know my life is very much
martial arts uh acting acting class and
auditions I guess and you know family
and my girlfriend is pretty it's pretty
simple and sounds like you're very
disciplined does that come from the
martial arts or did you see that from
one of your parents I think that it does
a lot come from the martial arts I think
it gives you a certain work ethic but I
think the biggest thing that influences
me it is wanting it really badly I feel
like I really just just want it so bad
that it makes it a lot easier to be
disciplined when you really want
something how do you know another actor
that you're working with is good or is
is giving you something back is in the
moment with you well I mean you some
actress you definitely feel it feel it
more than you do with other actors but
it's not my job to judge anyone it's my
job to it's my job to work with them and
I'm just gonna listen and I'm just gonna
and I'm just gonna believe what they
tell me but yeah I mean definitely when
you work with someone really strong and
you feel it
that's really nice to have it's
definitely nice work with people who are
really dedicated to what they're doing
but it's not my job to judge anyone oh
it's my job to work with them so it
sounds like it's almost um it's I think
this sounds like so like new age or
whatever it's like it's like something
you're feeling almost like in the pit of
your stomach with the other person that
they're present for you yeah Robbie no
you put your attention on the other
person you look them in the eyes and he
listened and sometimes you know you're
gonna feel more with a certain actor
than you can feel with another actor but
I mean I'm not going to sit there and
judge anyone went because then I'm not
in the moment and then if i'm not in the
moment then how are they going to listen
to me and then get the best performance
out of them I you get the acting should
be selfless it's about what they're
talking about it's not about you so I
think that you know just you just gotta
remind yourself to like you know there
are times I mean you're a human being
there times that you're going to kind of
pop out or whatever of concentration and
you just got to put your you know again
put your focus on them and recenter
yourself and you know whatever happens
happens spontaneity like this dog the
kids were my so cute i wish i could see
the song hopefully I'm not thinking
about my lines her performance at all in
a perfect world I I don't know I tried
to prepare a lot I and just kind of let
it rip you know I have a point of view
I'm prepared to know what I'm saying I
know why I'm saying and I know
everything I'm saying and why and
everything you know is understood and
everything's understood i'm not really
necessarily thinking about it but then
if I do find myself thinking about it
then the next tape on take I'm like okay
recenter look at the person listen to
them and just kind of let it go and you
know there's times that are going to be
easier than other times and uh you're
human and things are going to come in
and out it's not like you can just a
hundred percent always be in it but but
you know you try your best to just focus
on the other person
who are some actors that you admire oh
man that's hard there's so many I really
like Joseph gordon-levitt a lot he's
really cool and he's a great example of
someone who started out young and really
made a great transition Leonardo
DiCaprio's great Jeremy Renner is really
good a lot a lot of people I really like
what about classes like actors who have
passed on from Steve McQueen okay
awesome Steve McQueen James Dean there
they're all great you know there's
something you can learn from everyone
for Brando there's a lot of great great
great examples of a you know people
learn from it and see and that's the
thing as you look at someone like Steve
McQueen he was uniquely Steve McQueen
and I think that that's always an
important perspective to keep is be
yourself and bring yourself to every
role so have you studied them if you
like I mean just watched every film turn
the sound down watch how they move do
you know you know I i watch probably
first as a fan and then I I read a lot
of interviews I wanted me to watch a lot
of movies but I read a lot of interviews
of people like if I like someone I see
that especially if they're starting to
pop I see what they're doing in and see
kind of what other people have in common
with you know other people who are doing
really well in my field I think that
it's a smart thing to read interview see
what they did you know see what they
they said that worked the things they
said that didn't work but yeah I watch a
lot of movies both you know older and
contemporary and just a lot of times i'm
watching is a fan honestly because i
love movies that's why that's why i do
this i but yeah I mean there's a lot
especially if it's something that like
you get this the sag screeners for
what's going to be nominated those I
definitely try to watch critically and
be like what you know that was really
interesting choice of that person made
or like a loved foxcatcher this last
year that was my favorite that and
whiplash I really like if you weren't
acting what would you be doing let's
suppose that just for some reason you
said you know what I'm gonna take a
break organic farm on man okay so here's
the thing I I don't know maybe something
with martial arts but i never have a
back-up plan because i think it gives me
like that certain little air bubble of
like the possibility I could fail so
I've never really had a back-up plan so
I'd never really try to think about it
because I don't want to think that I
would
have to do anything else hopefully you
know knock on wood somewhere that I
could do this for the rest of my life it
makes me happy i love being on set I
love creating in general i love you know
whether it's doing a short you know with
your friends in their backyard or doing
a movie you're dependent film like this
or doing a studio film or being on TV
it's any day I get to act is awesome why
do you want it so bad ah man there there
a lot of reasons I because because it
makes me happy and you I feel like you
have to get to a certain place to where
you can be doing it to the I guess
extent that I want to do it I want to be
able to one day hopefully be able to
pick what I do you know I mean I am as
like ninety-nine point nine percent of
actors are I'm you know part of that
audition grind I want it so bad because
one day I want to be able to go you know
I really want to do this I really want
to do this and at least my name be in
the discussion of you know even if I
slept audition for it if it's you know
if I'm on their their top list of people
that would be really cool but I want to
be able to do what i want one day so I
think that's probably the main reason I
wanted really really badly so bad how
many actors do you know that are in that
space that that have that pick and
choose sort of like personally ah like
one or two like not not many you know
and even friends I have what I
would consider like killing it the soft
audition they're just you know at a like
a different level of it they're like in
the discussion you know in the short on
ppl shortlist for a project but I mean
it's a very small group of people